[Music]
all right for this one i'm not even
gonna say anything i'm just gonna play
something that is a new release it's a
great video game that is
about to be out i think you guys will
enjoy it
thank you um you got that kind of
reaction yeah why you laughing so much
stop laughing like that it's the dumbest
[ __ ] this is a hentai game that he's
been working on huh ah yes okay here it
is hentai
what's that shut the [ __ ] up
oh
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that bro
that was monetizing over [ __ ] killing
people and why did it have to be rap i
know why do you have a rap that's insane
he wants us to show his like how cool
what's the thing about his royalties so
there was a lot of footage right so it
kind of exonerated him and it made a lot
of people think like okay let me rethink
this whole situation now that we looked
at the evidence maybe he wasn't as bad
as we thought and then he goes hey let
me [ __ ] that up for myself
[Laughter]
let me stop you there
he killed a [ __ ] child molester and
then he killed some other guy who was
like you know a sketchy dude there you
go i was like i saw that all of his
cards fell in place yeah it all worked
out can i ask you a question now he's
ruining it yeah when you see stuff like
this do you go i made the right choice
to move here
you go like i can't wait to get my
american citizenship
no i think about that all the time i
love the diversity yeah
i mean that's you know i love stuff
about this country and then there's this
what is the british and japanese
equivalent of that because they they
exist all over the world what like
british rap no the people like this
[ __ ] geeks that don't take showers
and [ __ ] i mean like
i don't know
no i mean there's a high level like
serious killers in japan yeah there is a
japanese equivalent where i forget when
it happened but this guy he was a
foreign exchange student and he killed
he murdered a uh i think a french
student in france and then the french
government didn't want to take care of
it so they sent him back to japan
but um japan didn't want to take care of
it either so they send them back they
keep going back and forth basically i
think he did some time but it's totally
free yeah he's released but then because
of the crazy story he was in the media
and he sells books and i think he still
makes money off of it and then how i
killed his friends
yeah they would just kill her though he
didn't just kill her what are you doing
wait is it the weird guy that eat that
eight yeah he ate her yeah
yeah yeah he's weird dude how
hard-working of a guy and he got him on
the interview
cannibalism yeah even like he looks
weird he looks [ __ ] weird yo it's
close to that weird porn story you're
saying too i think they a porn director
got him on and they didn't tell the
actress who he was and i think while
they were having sex they told her like
what he had done
oh my god and then she yeah it was she
probably felt disgusting so when he was
eating her out she all right no below
this guy
just just typing
rides the [ __ ]
japanese cannibal
yeah he will pop up you'll find joe
right next to him going like this hey
but i eat a [ __ ] okay not like this guy
he's like a baller weirdo and he made
his money i don't even like talking
about him because people are gonna you
know buy his book
but that's how hard working asian people
are we can do anything guys
stop asian hate it's like
[Laughter]
all right let's do another search
japanese guy eats a lot of [ __ ] joe
again
no it's this guy
oh yeah he looks
weird man
i like his younger picture he looked
really [ __ ] weird turtleneck is a
[ __ ] weirdo weirdo dude
you're [ __ ] british it's different
yeah yeah
you guys are wearing turtlenecks for no
reason all the time
98 degrees turtle day i like kidding i
like hitting up someone wearing a
turtleneck what's up you eat french
people
[Laughter]
what do you mean turtleneck [ __ ]
we all know what that means you're one
of them extradition
[ __ ] yeah this guy is [ __ ] up can we
see how much people have donated or not
donated for is it like a yeah it's like
a kickstarter or a vehicle
thing
let's see
sure looks like it was made on like two
flash games crazy as there are like kyle
[ __ ] fans oh there's die hard right
now i'm gonna have a
because aside from whatever happened
legally
the concept of like a 18 year old or
however old he was going like oh there's
some crazy [ __ ] going down i'ma go save
the world that means you're a [ __ ]
weirdo yeah
i'm gonna protect this parking lot like
who the [ __ ] cares dude go home dweeb
[ __ ] virgin
you had [ __ ] you would have never done
this you had a girlfriend yeah you
brought the roll out
the biggest virgin move i've ever seen
in my life i'm gonna protect this target
can you imagine david yelling down at
him but he's just like ah
i'm not even attacking him you're a
[ __ ]
go home little virgin little virgin i'm
protecting my country sure you are
virgin go on oh she's a [ __ ] walmart
dude he's standing in front of walmart
like no
this is what called him a dweeb yeah it
doesn't it doesn't say what how much
money it's made so far but i'm sure it's
been taken off i mean
plus it's a it just has accounts it's
probably really fun
aside from that advocate i kind of want
to play it
aside from him
shooting turkeys that's kind of fun
it's like the rap song
yeah why did he use rap yeah yeah black
people love this let me give it a try
i'm gonna score some gobble gobble
gobble
just like
like it's like
come on man
yeah i just want to punch him in the
face now is it just him or like him and
the people around him that
make that happen you know i think it's a
whole political party around defense
making it happen
i mean
my question is why is it turkey's
because i thought he was shooting human
beings
i think the idea of a turkey shoot right
like a turkey shoot conceptually is when
you have like everything in one spot so
you can just go off on it like people
used to call turkey shoots when they
would like dig [ __ ] holes in ones and
people get trapped in those [ __ ] like
a ditches and everyone around would just
be able to fire him off like it's a fire
squad so the idea that this guy
because i'm [ __ ] racist dog okay
i'm like what is this
no that's literally what was considered
a turkey shoe so the idea that like you
know you have nothing but just targets
it's targets you know what i'm saying
which is probably the situation he was
in
he's so weird because i specifically
remember because i did a podcast on this
[ __ ]
with him no i was with him
out the other day i dropped him off he
literally said i just want to disappear
and i want people to leave me alone and
he does stupid [ __ ] like this yeah
you're the most unlikable human being on
earth and you're a virgin [ __ ]
weird enough about her
dude you still got a hymen
i think you're gonna hide me in your
penis [ __ ]
what's up dog she still can't even break
his dick cherry
kyle written hyman dude that's his name
he's german written
[Laughter]
stupid he's gonna cry like he did in
court when he hears that nickname
and i was like what three years ago two
years ago juvenile technically
yeah
19 he's 19. yes yeah see every video or
picture i see him in he's always got a
backwards hat dude like that's his
signature look
because when you do this
he's that sign of a virgin
virgin he's like oh
this guy's not a bird
that couldn't be any more forward
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's not a written hymen
that's nice i regret that i got lost my
virginity at 17 i feel like i should
have lost it earlier
i would have thought you lost weight
earlier you know what though i um i had
a rule for myself i was like all these
people all my age when i was like 14 13
there are being [ __ ] sexually active
right and i said i think i'm gonna do it
with a girl that's a virgin that's my
number one rule so then every time like
i'll be like you can suck my dick you
can jack me off
but you can't have any of this v card
baby
because i'm special
because you that's why i'm like and you
better not lie either are you a virgin
she goes nope and i'm like
no way hussy not with you
as soon as you call her
hold up she still stuck your dick
she's like that's your right
wait you were really holding out for a
birthday girl i wanted it to be yeah
with i just wanted to be uh uh uh equal
you wanted to trade cards all these
[ __ ] wanted to [ __ ] your dick but
they weren't very so they're just
sucking it three oh two or three two or
three but i was i was i was 16 17. i
think i was 17. but you were still
religious at this time huh right i still
prayed but i was non-denominational my
friend nice to meet you i was a karate
warrior
backwards
i was doing good
i love my god but i'm gonna cherry pick
the rules that i want to believe in you
know what i mean you know what that is
you're a good christian dude
oh [ __ ] you're hat you're right oh [ __ ]
hey
wait when you first did it were you
happy with your decision
when i first did it yeah yeah i don't
even remember the first time honestly i
remember the first time
because you should not remember it
because usually you remember the first
time and then it's a blur
you know why
you know why you remember who it is no i
do it was my first like long-term
girlfriend
but the thing is
we fooled around a lot so like
it started off with months of hand
jobbing it probably could be weeks
for one ejaculation
and it could have been like lots of back
and forth oral yeah it was probably two
weeks of just projects should have been
done in a month but it was delayed you
lose your the city got involved
if you get your dick permits you don't
think that you lo that's losing your
virginity no
and i was playing with the [ __ ] because
i didn't enter the beat nope you are a
christian dude and then [ __ ]
it happened but i don't even remember
that day i don't even remember remember
no none of that do you remember if you
use a condom or not yeah
i didn't use a condom because i was too
ashamed to go buy it so then we did it
and then i busted in her mouth
nice because i learned that through porn
yeah
you bought a condom and then you busted
on your muscles special dude
i'm calling lost
[Laughter]
you